hey what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here
remember a boon to phone OS you know we
have Android Windows Phone blackberry
iOS boot iPhone OS is kind of the new
player on the market and we've first
really got to see in action at CES in
January of this year and I also did a
top five video of detailing the best
features of it it's basically a new
smartphone operating system with a lot
of unique features that other smartphone
OSS don't have it all well funny you
should mention that a boot to edge is
the newest thing that has all the people
talking asking questions like is this
legit is this really as awesome as it
looks is this really what I think it is
that's what we're here to answer so
without any further ado let's take a
closer look this is a boon to edge
explain there are three main things you
need to know about a boon to edge to
really understand it number one this is
a crowdfunding project to make a piece
of hardware happen basically this device
doesn't exist yet canonical which is a
company in charge of this is trying to
make it happen in the form of an
IndieGoGo campaign so the first link
below the like button will be a link to
the whole campaign page where you can
read up on all the details and check it
out and see for yourself but they're
asking for a record 32 million dollars
to make this one device happen but when
you think about it in terms of you know
actual costs to make a smart phone when
you compare it to other high-end
flagship smartphones that's not all that
much money at all to ask for and this is
also a limited edition phone so it might
seem crazy at first to ask for a world
record-breaking 32 million dollar
fundraiser on IndieGoGo but when you put
it all in perspective it's not all that
insane the number two thing you need to
know is the actual specs of the device
they're planning to make they're really
weird this device is supposed to have a
4.5 inch 720p display covered with a
sheet of sapphire crystal instead of
traditional glass it also have a camera
on the back similar to the HTC ones in
that it's optimized for low-light
photography and fast shooting sounds
kind of like the HTC One S camera it'll
probably come in at around 4 or 8
megapixels you've also quoted the
fastest multi-core chip available which
will probably be an 8 core chip by the
time this phone launches plus they're
also looking at 4 gigabytes of RAM and
128 gigabytes of flash storage damn that
is a stat line right there in that one
frame of their promo video that's
sold a lot of people those those three
things are just nuts also have dual LTE
antennas for 4G in Europe and the USA
and a slightly new silicon anode battery
technology for a hopefully very
long-lasting battery in this beast of a
phone and it'll dual boot Android and a
boon to so why all these crazy specs why
all these ridiculous numbers on paper
well consider this the idea of an Ubuntu
OS phone is that wing and holding in
your hand or when it's in your pocket it
will run a normal phone operating system
like Android and you won't be able to
tell that it's a crazy phone or anything
like that but once you plug it in and
basically dock it to a display a
keyboard and maybe even a mouse it'll
start running a full desktop operating
system they're using a boon to so a full
full fledged
desktop non stripped-down experience
that's going to take a pretty crazy spec
sheet to be able to run that and fit in
your pocket the bow 2 edges Hardware
also happens to look just gorgeous
drop-dead gorgeous beautiful sexy did I
mention gorgeous you have mostly 3d
renders at the moment but looks like if
you look at the campaign site some
actual prototyping has started as they
have a couple of physical things in hand
that they can use to show off the phone
but when you actually look at this it's
very very clean the idea of the clean
lines of the edge it'll be crafted from
a single piece of metal into an awesome
shape for this high-end build quality
and on front you can see edge to edge
sapphire crystal to make a bun to OS as
gestures much easier since you're not
dragging your finger over multiple
materials and honestly what the angles
on the devices and the way the corners
look I can see where they got the name
edge makes a lot of sense and I also
happen to think this looks a lot like
the Oppo find 5 but maybe that's just me
so the number 3 thing you need to know
and this is probably the most critical
of them all is how does this actually
work how do you have a device that runs
Ubuntu OS and Android how do you have
something that has two different
operating systems on it that work with
each other and talk to each other well
the answer that canonical has come up
with they're calling convergence
conversions is basically Android and a
boon to OS being able to talk to each
other which is pretty freaking cool now
they don't actually have in a boon to
edge to show us this on so for the video
they had a much lower spec device they
use in Nexus 4 and basically when they
plugged in the Nexus 4 they were using
you know stock
Android before you couldn't tell that it
was an abuti phone but they plugged into
the desktop and it was running full a
guest like we said before a boon to
operating system for the desktop and
since these two operating systems are
talking to each other using this
convergence a lot of the things that you
would expect to find in your phone you
will start to also find on the boon -
desktop so if you use the contacts app
in a boon - and you start searching for
contacts you're going to be searching
the contacts on your Android phone the
music on the Ubuntu desktop will search
for songs in your Ubuntu library on
Android the Thunderbird mail client gets
its data from the Gmail client on the
Android phone and you can even use a
dialer app in the desktop to make and
receive phone calls through the phone
that's plugged in so it's a really neat
concept and basically what I'm trying to
say is where can I give you my money so
what's the point of all this what's the
big idea with making a high-end device
that runs abouttwo OS well basically you
can consider the abou to edge the nexus
of Ubuntu OS it's basically using this
project to create a limited edition
high-end phone that is you know a blend
of the experience of what the experience
should be when you're using this
operating system so again when we look
at the nexus program for android you're
looking at what you expect out of stock
Android this is what you should expect
out of a boon to OS when you're going to
be running a high-end operating system
from the desktop you're going to need
high-end specs this is what they want to
start off with and what other OEMs can
follow this isn't meant to be an iPhone
rival or the most popular thing in the
world it's not going to sell well again
this is limited edition it is only for
the enthusiasts it is only for the
people that are supporting the project
so that's basically yeah they're doing a
great job right now one thing I kind of
want to see if they're even watching
this or listening at all is I would kind
of like to see a physical and actual
physical doc because the idea of you
know plugging in one cable and sort of
propping up your phone next to your
desktop seems a little bit cumbersome if
that's something what they want us to be
doing all the time with the edge and I'd
also like to see a little bit more
prototyping so they have some more
physical units to be able to show people
if they're trying to get bigger
donations from people who are interested
but other than that they're kicking ass
right now if you've checked out the
IndieGoGo campaign already you'll see it
seems like they're going up by a few
thousand dollars every time i refresh
the page on IndieGoGo so they're kicking
ass right now and I really hope they
reach there
thirty two million dollar goal how
realistic is it that they're going to
reach this goal it's a good question I
mean they did indeed smash records they
I think hit two million dollars in the
first 24 hours and this is a thirty day
campaign and four days in their past six
and a half million dollars so it seems
like they're doing a great job already
but uh it's it's definitely something
that needs to be kick-started if you get
punt that I just made that idea but
either way if you feel like getting this
super kick started you can just you know
toss eighty thousand dollars at them I'm
sure they could use that either way this
has been a boon to edge explain feel
free to share this video with anyone who
has any questions about this also I'll
include a link to the AMA on reddit that
CEO Mark Shuttleworth did which has a
lot of interesting questions about the
business and technology behind the
scenes answer there so I'll include that
link below the like button below
hopefully this covers everything if you
have any other comments or questions
the discussion section is open below
thank you for watching and I'll talk to
you guys in the next one hey